One of the most deceptively complicated tasks
of building a Magic: the Gathering deck is
constructing a manabase. Deceptively complicated
in no small part because it’s not what people
think about when they think about their deck,
particularly in EDH. If somebody asks you what’s
going on in your Prosper deck, you’re not gonna
say “I’m glad you asked! It’s running 35 lands,
six two mana rocks, and a Sol Ring, with an
even blend of 21 black and 21 red symbols and
an approximately 15% tapland saturation.” That
would be strange! And yet, lands are one of the
most important parts of a deck, allowing it to do
all of the things that might give it identity and
excite the person who plays it. Lands are
the foundation upon which a deck is built,
and as with construction a shaky foundation will
lead to a shaky deck. Now, the good news here is
that I’m not necessarily going to be asking you to
spend more time thinking about your manabase. In
just a bit I’ll be telling you about a brand new
tool I created in collaboration with my brother,
a tool that can be used to rapidly diagnose
issues with manabases and point to possible
solutions. But first, I want to lay a bit
more groundwork for why manabases are hard,
just so that you have an idea of the sort of
challenges this tool will be trying to solve.
Typically the question of manabases
begins with color symbol split,
which makes sense. At a limited event such as a
prerelease, the most primordial of deckbuilding
experiences most players will engage in, you’re
best served to build a 40-card deck with 17 lands,
and however many lands you need can only
be fulfilled with basics. The fundamentals
are the same between limited and EDH—you need to
figure out a collection of lands that do a decent
job of allowing you to cast your spells. This
will have to do with how total symbol counts of
different colors compare, but also how intense
symbol requirements are and how early cards are
expected to be needed. A Ball Lightning has the
same total symbol requirement as three Shocks,
but those two selections of cards apply very
different levels of demand on a deck’s red mana.
Likewise, Counterspell has the same mana cost
as Master of Pearl Trident or Counterbalance,
but it generally applies less strain on a deck’s
blue mana since it’s a reactive card that will
likely be played later in the game. If you want
a video that focuses more heavily on that, Rebell
Lily also happened to release a two part series
about lands this month, and her manabase video
does a good job discussing the timing of different
mana values. A link to that is in the description.
The task of symbol management exists in
all formats—limited, 60-card constructed,
and EDH—but when it comes to how this task is
accomplished, things diverge. Whereas in limited
your task will generally be to create the least
bad manabase you can out of basics and whatever
nonbasics you were lucky enough to get your hands
on, in EDH your options will be a whole lot less,
well, limited. Dual lands can simply be
put in your deck, and not just guildgates
or gain-1 lands—a plethora of different
high-quality fixing lands are available,
from pain lands to fetches to triomes and beyond.
The available fixing is so good, in fact, that
EDH decks often include some number of lands which
are lackluster in their color-producing abilities,
instead played for other benefits they provide.
These are usually called utility lands. But how
many of these is it appropriate to play? Well, I
actually like to think of land bases of decks as
existing to hit two different goals. One of these
goals is covering a deck’s symbols—lands exist to
produce the colors of mana needed to cast a deck’s
spells. The other goal of a land base is covering
total mana values, itself assisted by hitting
land drops—hitting your land drops consistently
is generally quite important to the success
of casual EDH decks, more so than most other
formats in Magic, so decks will be best served
to run enough lands to consistently hit their
land drops. Land count video is in the description
if you want to hear more about that. Okay, so
we’ve got two goals to cover with this one thing,
our deck’s lands. One function of utility lands,
then, is to bridge gaps between these two—if a
deck wants 37 lands for purposes of hitting its
land drops, but only needs 33 lands to produce an
acceptable number of symbols to cast its spells,
that leaves four slots for colorless-producing
utility lands. There are more factors at play
here that we’ll get into a bit later, but
this is a simplified version of things.
Okay, so with that background out of the way,
we’re ready to talk about the tool. Before I
get into that, though, this tool took a ton of
effort to make and it’s available for free, so…
let’s talk about my sleeves. All of my decks are
in Dragonshield sleeves, have been for at least a
year now, and the durability on these is really a
game changer for me. Back several years ago when
my playgroup had a collective deck pool sleeved
up in another popular brand, I was infamous for
constantly breaking sleeves with my thorough
and heavy-handed shuffling. With my current
Dragonshields, though, breaking sleeves is quite
a rarity, even with my shuffling. They also have
a fantastically wide array of different color
options—I’ve got this offensively-saturated
magenta for my Liesa deck, a meaty copper color
for my Malfegor deck, and this pleasant peach
color for my Radha deck. Those peach sleeves are
dual mattes, so they’ve also got a dark background
from the front—it makes for a cool aesthetic,
particularly with extended-art cards and alters
such as this one. Big thanks to Dragonshield for
supporting the channel! Alright, so the motivation
behind this tool is basically that there are a ton
of unique ways to screw up a mana base—poor color
pip distribution, inadequate overall pips, too
many taplands for a deck’s intended play pattern,
not enough overall lands, and so on. For any given
dual land cycle there will often be some decks
where they’ll work well and others where they’ll
work poorly, and some decks will require more
nonbasic fixing than others. With this in mind, I
had a vision for a tool in the months following my
lands video last year, a tool that could quickly
identify potential issues with a deck’s manabase
and offer suggestions for improvement. This
idea sat around on my “to-do-at-some-point”
list for a few months before I decided that
it wasn’t going to get done and that I should
pawn it off on my brother, Ian, who helped me
with the coding on some previous calculators
on my website. Since this was his work, I’ll
have him go into the basic guts of the thing.
Hi, I’m Ian, and I’m the one who built this thing.
To understand how well a manabase functions,
we want to model how it will perform in-game.
Fully simulating commander games is beyond the
scope of this project, so instead we need
to simplify it into a form that we know we
can work with. My other calculators
used a hypergeometric distribution,
which is a fancy sounding name for some
fancy looking math that gives us exactly
what we’re looking for. If we’re drawing a
certain number of cards from a deck with a
certain number of cards of a given category,
it will tell us the exact odds of drawing a
certain number of cards of that category. If
we calculate this for every possible number of
that type we could draw, we will get every
possible outcome and its probability.
On its own, this only tells us about one
category, but we can get more. While working
on the last batch of calculators, I came up
with a way to calculate the odds for every
possible combination of multiple categories
using a branching tree-like structure. So if
we can sort all the lands in a deck into a
set of categories, we can use this to find
every combination of lands that we can draw, and
then check whether they let us cast our spells.
There are plenty of ways we could come up with
these categories, but I decided to just have
one category for each possible combination of
the 5 colors, giving us a total of 32. This is
also the number of unique values that can be
represented by 5 bits, which means that if we
number these categories just right, the bits
that store the number for each category will
also store the combination of colors its lands
can produce. If we’re willing to get our hands
dirty with some bit-level operations, we can get
a ton of mileage out of these categories. This
is ultimately how we determine if a set of lands
can cast a spell, but that process is a little too
complicated to explain here. (Show list of numbers
0-31 in binary, then replace 1s with color pips)
If we test every combination of lands to see if
they can cast a spell, we can get a probability
for how often a given number of lands will be
able to cast a given spell. By running this for
different numbers of lands, we can get an idea
of how many lands we need to cast the spell,
and by factoring in the land count of the deck we
can figure out when we will draw those lands. This
lets us determine how often we can cast a spell on
curve, and how much time we spend waiting for the
right lands to cast it. If we do this for all the
spells in a deck and average the results, we can
get an overall representation of how well a deck’s
manabase can cast its spells. Once we have a way
to score a manabase like this, we can test out
small changes to find the best way to improve it.
So this is the backbone of the tool—average delay
in casting spells is the benchmark here that is
used to judge decks, alongside “Cast Rate” which
here means how likely it is that a card will be
castable on a turn on or before its mana value.
The tool also tests small changes in the deck,
seeing how it is changed by adding in a single
basic land for each type among the deck’s colors,
as well as a wastes. This is helpful for
pointing out which colors are most needed, and
the inclusion of wastes also gives insight about
how a deck’s land count is looking. Adding a waste
to a deck shouldn’t really help it cast spells
with less delay, or at least it should help a
lot less than adding something that actually taps
for colors. If adding a waste reduces the average
delay of a deck by a substantial amount, that’s
a good indicator that it might need more lands,
or at least that land count is a bigger problem
for it than color-fixing. As an example here,
let’s put my Malfegor deck through this thing.
Okay, list pasted here from Archidekt, commander
name here, how important is the commander? I’d
say it’s a nice bonus for a deck that’s still
functional without it. That selection just tells
the tool how heavily to weight the commander in
its calculations, since some decks really care
about whether they can cast the commander,
whereas others such as this one don’t care nearly
as much. Load, that all looks good, let’s compute.
Hmmm. So this is actually worse than I expected.
After plugging in a discount for my one delve
card, that cast rate is okay but not amazing.
When we look at how improvements affect it,
the amount that adding a waste reduces the
average delay is a little on the high side.
This tool wouldn’t mind the deck having
more lands, probably because it has a six
mana commander that is still being weighted
a bit higher than other cards in the deck,
but it’s not terribly-terribly bad. The swamp
figure is barely higher than the wastes figure,
which basically means this deck is doing great for
black mana, no notes. The red figure, on the other
hand, is a lot worse, and when I look at this deck
I can kinda see it—there are 18 red symbols among
the lands and 3 among the mana rocks for a total
of 21, which is an okay figure but certainly not
wildly high. What cards is this most likely to be
a problem for? Well, I can tab over for that—this
table shows the likelihood of playing each card
on curve. The highest delay here is the commander,
a four symbol six drop, but what about after that?
As you might expect, other double red cards. Ox of
Agonas is a card that’ll typically be getting cast
after Malfegor, so later in the game than turn 5,
and this is likewise somewhat true for Fiery
Confluence, which is a more reactive card.
However, Glint-Horn Buccaneer is a card
that is more likely to be wanted on-curve,
and for that reason it may be worth cutting
given the deck’s very black-centered manabase.
Immediately with this showcase, a lot of
the assumptions of the tool become clear.
There is an expectation that it is desirable
to play cards on curve—I know that Ox of Agonas
and Fiery Confluence don’t need to be played on a
turn equivalent to their respective mana values,
but the tool doesn’t know that. While
working with Ian on dealing with edge cases,
I briefly considered some sort of weighting
scheme involving card types. So, for example,
instants are more often reactive than other
types, meaning that it will be desirable to
play an instant on curve less often than it
would be desirable to play a creature or an
artifact on curve. If we wanted to maximize the
accuracy of the model, we could add some sort of
weight for this like was done for the commander,
telling the model to care some percent less about
instants for the purposes of these curve-out
calculations. However, this gets at one of the
most challenging conflicts when building a tool
such as this—accuracy vs interpretability. A
model that takes in more factors and adds more
weights will be able to produce results that
are more accurate, but they also make the model
harder to understand, harder to pick apart, harder
to think about. A model with too much unexplained
complexity becomes a black box that its users must
be expected to blindly trust, and that’s frankly
an unreasonable thing to ask. No, better to have
an imperfect but somewhat simpler model that
people can open the hood on, so to speak, and
check out the inner workings of before deciding
how they should be considering its outputs.
This principle applies to other aspects of the
tool as well. For example, I mention in my land
count video that draw can be used to find
additional lands. This is true in principle,
but there are enough factors and caveats present
to make things more than a little muddy. For one,
as I mention in that video, higher costed draw
must be treated carefully in this regard—a 4 or
5 mana draw spell shouldn’t be treated as a way
to find lands in a deck with 32 lands and 6 ramp
spells, since in a decent portion of games you
won’t even draw into enough lands to get there
without missing a land drop in the first place. A
3 mana draw spell that requires additional factors
to be met such as a large creature entering is
also tricky, as it prompts a whole different suite
of questions—how often will you have the creature?
How much does the creature cost? Can you afford
it? Here we run into both technical limitations
and interpretability limitations—in technical
terms, a more sophisticated simulation that
understands the text of more cards and is
willing to play through more actions can figure
out how effective these sorts of draw spells are
in finding lands, but setting up and running
this sort of model is labor-intensive and
computationally expensive, respectively. Even
if we solve the technical issues, getting into
more complex cards effectively requires that
the simulation make strategic decisions on
behalf of a hypothetical player, and this fact
destroys the interpretability of the results.
How are players supposed to know the sorts of
decisions the model is making on their behalf?
These limitations lead to the implemented
solution here—treating cards that might
help find lands as a portion of a land. This is
what Frank Karsten does in his land-counts model,
though he excludes draw spells above two
mana due to the aforementioned complicating
factors. My team ultimately decided not
to include any draw spells in the model,
not even the low-cost ones, and this was
for a couple reasons. For one, EDH doesn’t
have the low-cost draw spell density that other
formats have. Ponder has a 13% play rate in EDH,
which certainly isn’t low, but it’s pretty
meager compared to a format like Legacy,
where cantrips and filtering often make up
10-20% of a deck by volume. In addition,
I don’t even know if it’s necessarily appropriate
to assume that low-cost filtering spells are being
used to find lands in most cases—in formats with
less forgiving mulligan rules they might fill that
role by necessity reasonably often, but in EDH
a turn 1 ponder could just as easily be used to
shuffle away a top three cards containing two
lands. Still, in most other ways this model
chose to take a similar set of assumptions as
Karsten. Ramp is effectively counted as a portion
of a land that can tap for colors corresponding to
whatever fixing the specific card could provide,
with its exact weight determined by how
often a deck will be able to cast it on
curve. This in effect means that higher-costed
ramp is weighted lower than lower-costed ramp,
particularly in decks with fewer lands, which
intuitively makes sense to me. This solution
misses a bit of nuance in that a lot of decks
play ramp to cast cards ahead of curve, but fully
modeling that would require an inordinate amount
of effort, and has similar issues to accounting
for higher-costed draw. It’s a good enough
solution for the intent of the tool, though.
Something that some players might
object to about the presentation of the
tool is the lack of in-your-face direction.
There are some colors, some vague pointers,
and numbers provided about some specific cards,
but not really any specific figures that are set
out as what people should be shooting for as far
as overall manabase quality goes. This is a flaw
in some ways, but it’s a benefit in the sense that
it allows for the presence of a key guiding hand
in manabase construction—risk tolerance. See,
different people will run different numbers of
lands and densities of symbols depending on how
comfortable they are with the risk of getting
mana screwed. Running a lower land count may mean
mana screw some games, but it could also result in
more gas. For somebody deckbuilding with the
sole goal of winning, such as a cEDH player,
it may be worth it to run a land count that leads
to missing land drops and having stallouts in some
games if those downsides are counterbalanced
by more explosive win potential at other points
in time. Meanwhile, somebody just looking to
have a fun time might scoff at this approach,
wanting a more consistent range of experiences.
Utility lands follow a similar principle—running
a higher density of colorless-producing utility
lands allows a player’s lands to contain more,
well, utility, *but* it also makes casting
spells more difficult. How many utility lands are
correct? Well, it really depends on how heavily
you prioritize the advantage of having abilities
on your lands, and how much you’re willing to
risk having trouble casting spells. This tool
tries to avoid making declarative statements
on how comfortable with risk players should be,
but what it does do is try to make it
clear to players the sort of territory
they’re lurking in. If you’re running a
dangerously high number of utility lands
or a very slim land count, I don’t want
to be here to tell you not to do that,
but what I do want to do is make sure it’s
clear to you that that’s what you're doing.
So, all that covers the color considerations,
which is really the heart of the model,
but there’s also an element that is quite
relevant to all my fellow budget deckbuilders
out there—taplands. Taplands are a little tricky
because they’re related to a deck’s curveout and
overall manabase, but in very complicated
ways that are difficult to have an algorithm
suss out. However, it’s still a good thing for
people to have some data on, and to cover how we
integrated it, I’ll hand things back over to Ian.
One of the main compromises we made with the color
calculator was that we had it ignore whether
lands enter tapped. To compensate for this,
we can make a second model that calculates
for this while ignoring mana colors. To start,
we need to know how often our lands enter
tapped, especially the ones that only enter
untapped under certain conditions. None
of these conditions are too complicated,
so we can write a few simple algorithms to see how
often they enter tapped. Now we need to know what
impact that will have on our deck, which we can do
by simulating the opening turns. Using a heavily
simplified simulation, we can look at the first
several turns of thousands of games and score them
based on how many spells we can cast. Then, we can
run this two more times, once with no tap lands,
and once with one less tap land. This tells us
the overall impact of tap lands on the deck, along
with the improvement we can get from replacing
one of them with a land that enters untapped.
Part of the idea here was to make it clear how
often a land would enter tapped for a player,
so for example with something like a checkland
you’d need specific basic-typed lands, with a
tango land you’d need a decent density of actual
basic lands, and so on. Including a summary of how
often these will enter tapped can help players
double check that the budget dual lands they’re
adding are actually going to be working well for
them. Building commander decks is complicated,
and it’s pretty easy to throw in staples or
personal favorites absentmindedly, without
double checking every single one. This isn’t even
just an issue of budget dual land cycles—there are
an increasing number of utility lands with some
sort of check involved, which includes two cycles
originally printed in Throne of Eldraine, as well
as the recent cycle of lands printed in Modern
Horizons 3. While the tapped status of these lands
isn’t as important as that of a mana-only land,
one of these entering untapped 70% of the time vs
40% of the time could easily make the difference
in whether they’re worth running. This sort
of consideration also goes for lands with
requirements for tapping. The verges printed
in Duskmourn aren’t terribly problematic if
they’re not online, but there’s a different cycle
that is much more problematic in my mind—Tainted
lands. These aren’t strictly terrible—they always
enter untapped, and they might have a decently
high chance to tap for colored mana in a lot
of decks. I run one in my Malfegor deck, and it
feels pretty good there. However, in the context
of EDH they really only make sense in black-heavy
two color budget decks—with a Swamp count below
the mid-teens they won’t be reliable in their
colored production, and in any deck with a higher
budget there will be better options available.
One tricky thing with this sort of analysis is,
once again, the assumptions. The best example of
this is with a type of land I tend to be less of
a fan of compared to a lot of players—slow lands,
or dual lands that enter tapped unless a player
controls two or more other lands. This tool loves
these—when I throw my Radha deck into the tool and
check the odds of having lands tapped in the first
five turns of the game, we get a 15.3% chance for
Cinder Glade, a 14.7% chance for Copperline Gorge,
a 9.1% chance for Game Trail, and a frankly
absurdly low 1.5% chance for Rockfall Vale. Even
for a deck with a lower land count, the percent
chance to enter the battlefield tapped is still
quite low. Now, I’m not saying that slow lands are
bad—they’re better than a lot of types of budget
dual land out there, but they’re not ten times
better than other types of lands. This comes down
to the nuance that is missed by the % of time
tapped statistic—all the playtesting algorithm
cares about is whether or not it has two other
lands to play before the slow land. What if those
lands are a different type of conditionally-tapped
land with a different condition? What if the other
lands are the wrong color? What if one of
them is a Shadowmoor filter land that needs
an on-color mana to get working? All of these
are cases where the slow land contributes to
the malfunctioning of the manabase before turn
3, but they’re considered successes due to the
nature of the percent of time tapped metric. One
solution to this could be using a more complex
statistic than % of time tapped that takes more
factors into account, but—who’s that knocking?
That’s right, it’s our old friend,
interpretability. % of time tapped is
simply leaps and bounds more understandable than
any replacement statistic I could come up with,
and for that reason it’s worth
taking the L on cases such as this.
So, that’s basically the tool. There are a
couple extra caveats, one of which is that
this tool is naturally going to work better for
EDH decks that are closer in structure to most
60 card decks. A lot of the structure of the
model was based off the work of Frank Karsten,
who himself modeled much of his work on land
counts off of data captured from 60 card formats.
This data can be adapted to EDH, but it’s
naturally still not going to fully summarize
some EDH-specific types of decks. On that note,
it also works just fine for 60 card decks even
as it was made with the complexities of commander
in mind, so any 60 card format players out there
can just ignore the commander stuff and use
this normally. The other, potentially related,
caveat is that this tool is going to be less and
less helpful the more ramp and land focused a deck
is. Lands decks as an archetype obviously aren’t
going to be particularly well captured by this,
nor are decks that heavily employ ramp to get
a specific curve-out, such as my Radha deck.
Likewise, decks that specifically avoid paying
the costs of cards in their deck, such as a
reanimator deck or a Purphoros, Bronze-Blooded
deck, will likewise not be well-served by this
tool. We certainly tried to offer some ways
to adapt this tool to these sorts of decks,
which included a band aid solution of allowing
users to exclude cards from the analysis. This
makes a lot of problems go away in principle
without necessarily solving them. Ultimately,
I’m relatively fine with that compromise,
because at the end of the day, the people
doing creative curve-outs with strange tools
aren’t necessarily the ones this tool is intended
for. Me and Ian will likely work on building
an “advanced” version over the next month or
so with some extra factors and heuristics
built in for people who want more control,
because the audience for that does exist, it’s
just not the primary one we’re trying to cater to.
No, this tool is ultimately intended for the
people trying to build a deck focused on the
ways nonland cards work together, and just want a
manabase that doesn’t slow them down in that task.
I said in my video a year ago that people should
pay attention to their lands, and in my ramp video
two months prior to that that people should pay
attention to their ramp, but truly I understand
why people don’t want to focus on these things.
For a lot of decks, these things function more as
obstacles between them and a well-functioning
deck than they do as interesting tools to be
utilized in deck construction. A lot of players
feel ambivalent at best about their manabase,
and at worst may feel actively resentful of it.
A small but persistent minority of comments I see
on videos related to lands express something
to the effect that lands are a mistake, the
worst part of Magic: the Gathering, and a thing
to at best be tolerated as the price of playing
the game. Whether or not lands and mana make for
a fundamentally good mechanic is outside the scope
of this video, but for now I’ll just say to those
people—I see you, I hear you, and I want to make
your life a little easier. The gradual addition of
analysis features to deckbuilding sites is already
helping in this task to an extent—with a website
like Archidekt, you now have pip split, multiple
types of mana curve, a hypergeometric calculator
already linked to the deck’s categories,
and ways to get more granular in analysis, all at
your fingertips. There will always be the Spikes
out there who will crack open a hypergeometric
calculator for their different categories all on
their own, but the expansion of these tools to
be more readily available and easy to use is a
good thing, not just for the math-minded players,
but also for the players who just want a deck that
plays well without needing to spend an extra
hour or two diving into granular details. So,
this is a tool aimed principally at those players,
and really anybody who just wants a second set of
eyes on their manabase, something that can provide
immediate feedback and point to any potential
issues that may have been missed. If that sounds
cool to you, click the link in the description!
That caps off this video, but there was a ton
of stuff that we couldn’t talk about relating to
the tool. I recorded a separate interview with Ian
about those things, and it’s almost thirty minutes
long. I’m going to give a couple of previews
of that discussion here, and if it seems cool
you can subscribe to my Patreon for $3 a month to
gain access, or just buy access to that video for
$2 if you don’t want to add a new subscription,
also on Patreon. I’m getting back into producing
a bonus video every month in addition to my deck
reviews, and I have a back catalogue of more than
a dozen bonus videos that you can check out that
are a mixture of facecam videos, full-length ones
in my normal style, and endnotes for points that
couldn’t quite fit into a public video. You may
have also noticed the new background color on this
video, and that was also picked out by my patrons!
That’s a whole lot of great things about being a
Salubrious Snail patron if you ask me, you might
even get your name in the credits. With that said,
here’s a preview of my extra discussion with Ian.